okay and uh  he's making quite the grand entrance  yeah tonight  where is he  he has a man pulling him on the horse  the unofficial mayor  of dallas texas has arrived  from alabama  by way of tnt studios  it's juxta  [Applause]  to let go and i think you're really good  i grew up in alabama brother i know how  to ride a heart you do not know how to  use it very uncomfortable but hey  chuckster the hat looks good on you  brother  you look like a natural-born cowboy  dude no he doesn't look like that's not  dude  you look very uncomfortable hey  [Applause]  me please  all right let's see him i want to see  him get off yeah  this is always the test he cannot raise  that right hip over  the horse's head please fall oh he's  going backwards you're gonna please fall  oh my god  there you  [Applause]  go i told you  [Applause]  now it's your time shaq tell them  you gotta get them  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  the horse was kelly